cool casual and urban big prints a
playful mixture of finest materials
that's fashion from lala berlin to mark
the labels 10th birthday designer lineup
for desh showed off her current summer
collection in the carpentry workshop of
the deutsche oper Berlin lolly Berlin's
feminine metropolitan style is all the
rage in Germany's film and art scene the
sentence bonds very relaxed I always
loved the material mix asked the clay
does it preposterous i bought for myself
was in 2009 in Berlin's mid to districts
it was a lovely summer dress that
billowed and it was so soft I wanted to
put it on and fly away in it what's in
my Vicks leads Kenda looks like it's
fair I've been a fan for a fairly long
time it's great that it comes from
Berlin is individual and recognizable
Lila is a wonderful woman what a fuss
Lila Pradesh's worked as a designer for
10 years an Iranian she came to fashion
by chance she had studied business and
developed shows for a TV music channel
when she ran across some hand knitted
wrist warmers at a flea market in 2004
they inspired her to create her own
knitwear collection to smash excited I
think it was destination it simply came
my way faster descends or to me a good
communist she still loves wool and she
uses mohair marina Owen cashmere and her
designs her label is now sold in 250
boutiques around the world and at the
new lala berlin shop in the city's Mitte
district her breakthrough came with this
one hundred percent cashmere Palestinian
style keffiyeh scarf it became a classic
identity to harden physician having my
own identity and honesty are important
to me to look in the mirror in the
morning and be able to look myself in
the eye knowing what I do and how I
treat people bad as cotton candy these
are designs from the last five years
Lila Pradesh has remained true to
herself actors and models from all over
the world are crazy about these stylish
yet casual clothes from Berlin
back at the Deutsche OPA preparations
for the 10th anniversary show are in
full swing and the designer keeps
changing her mind about which looks to
present first
then via muslin and when we prepare a
show we produce and when we produce we
design so things are happening and you
all the time and we have to do this for
two seasons and there really is never a
breather stop illusion delusion that's
the title of Lila's spring/summer
collection for 2015
the birthday showing was one of the
highlights of the Berlin Fashion Week
Elvis if I think it was good I didn't
see it myself but I think it went off
well which rises successes 10 years of
lala berlin and Lila Pradesh's success
story a decade of designs that capture
the spirit of the times